you being Happy 10 hours a day selling
this even if it's a worse idea than
selling this is always going to win
attention is the number one asset in the
dating relationship me writing books and
things like that I really want to build
a business attached to it if you're in
my position what would you do I'm
thinking like hard games maybe the
mistake that most people make when they
built an audience and they're deciding
what am I going to sound is they think
that someone like me has the right
answer when they have the right answer
award could you sell courses you could
could you be a public figure and just
get paid for speaking you could could
you play a hair gel cuz your hair is
phenomenal you could you know you knew
and what you'll spend the extra hours
doing so you like it yeah yeah yeah you
being Happy 10 hours a day selling this
even if it's a worse idea than selling
this is always going to win the card
game is a thing now my
come that as someone who invests that
would only thing I would invest in cuz
it's burning a whole of you yeah